(audience clapping and cheering)
- Welcome back, y'all.
My next guest is one
of the best selling authors on the planet.
Since her debut novel in 2012,
she has sold over 40 million books
and redefined the fantasy genre.
Her latest is 'House of Flame and Shadow,'
the third book in her
Crescent City series.
This is amazing actually,
just check this out.
How many people actually showed up
to her midnight release party last week?
It's like Taylor Swift went somewhere.
(audience laughing)
Isn't like crazy?
Please welcome Sarah J Mass.
(audience clapping and cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Oh my God.
Well, welcome to our
show and congratulations.
- Oh my God.
I can't believe I'm here.
And they're puppies.
- I know.
- Is that where they are?
- You came on a good day.
- I'm taking all of them.
They're all spoken for now.
They're all coming home with me.
- That's actually really
hard for me not to do.
I'm like, I don't, I have
two children, two dogs.
I do not need anymore in
my house, but it's hard.
They're so cute.
- I know.
My 5-year-old son came with me here today.
And he just said to me,
mommy, I want Snowflake.
[Audience] Ahhh
[Kelly Clarkson] Ahhh
That's hard to...
- I think our 14-year-old dog at home
would have a heart attack and die
if I brought home Snowflake.
- That kind of energy is different.
Because I brought home Charlie to Henry
and they're like four
years difference, I think.
And Henry was not impressed.
I let my daughter get a dog
and Henry was like, what's happening here?
- Oh no.
- Yeah, they're fine now.
But do you get starstruck still
by authors like that you love?
- Yes, I cry every time I meet
someone that I really admire.
I don't know.
I have this reaction.
Because it's so intense that I,
my body just goes to tears.
- Yes, well, I think it's
when it's someone that
I have admired and whose
journey inspired my journey.
All of those emotions from like wishing
and hoping to like get to
that same point in my career.
- Inspiration.
- It hits me at once.
And I'll, like, I'll never forget,
I was at this book convention
and I was on a panel with
this author Tamara Pierce,
who I had like grown up reading.
I loved her books.
And I was on a panel with
her, like, as a peer,
like that, that shouldn't happen.
Like, I am not smart or cool enough
to be sitting next to this woman.
- I Have been in this situation musically.
And you're like, why am I here?
- And so I like walk in and
like sit down next to her
and I just, her name's
Tamara and I go, 'Hi Tammy.'
- (gasping)
You're like besties off the bat
- I wanted to die.
And she just was like
very, she was so gracious.
She was just like, oh,
hello. It's nice to meet you.
And then I just started telling her like,
I'm only here today because
of the work that you did,
because of the trail that you blazed.
- I bet that made her feel good.
- And I just, well, yes, but
I started sobbing like this.
And not like beautiful tears.
- Not Rachel McAdams, no.
- Mine were like (mimics crying)
And this was before a
panel was about to begin.
So there was a room full of
people there witnessing this.
Like absolute meltdown.
And thankfully she was so kind
and at the end of my
whole like sobbing rant,
she was just like, it's
very nice to meet you.
- You know what's interesting
though is you have now fans
that probably do that with you,
that you inspire and
you touch and they cry.
And you're like, no, I get it.
I'm like this with other people.
- Oh yeah, I know.
I'm like, I'm like, don't ever
be embarrassed by the tears.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- 'Cause I am that person.
And the tears are a wonderful thing.
Like it tells you
that it means
- [Kelly] Means it impacts you
- Something to you
Exactly, exactly
But then the, like, my
readers start crying
and then I start crying.
- I'm a contagious crier as well.
Someone cries on the couch and I'm like,
oh man, it's over.
- No, no..
- And I'm just, it's done.
The makeup's ruined for ever
- It's like, I wanna cry all the time.
What's happening?
I think it's called menopause, whatever.
- (laughing)
- But you say like, explaining the book
is kind of hard, right?
The new book.
Why do you think it, what can you tell us?
- Yeah, so this is the third book
in my Crescent City series.
- So you don't wanna ruin anything.
- Yeah, so no spoilers.
My lips are sealed.
But this series is kind of like a mashup
between like fantasy, paranormal romance,
little urban fantasy.
So it's a separate fantasy
world, but like a modern world.
So there are all these magical creatures
living in that world.
- Love, I'm in.
- And there's lots of like action
and a lot of like very steamy stuff.
- I'm in
- Lots of hot dudes.
- Alright.
- And then like, it's kind
of like all my other books,
I've got a couple different series
where they're all about like young women
finding their strength,
saving the day, kicking butt.
- Love it.
- Yeah, so there's that,
that's a big part of it.
- It must be hard to not be able to talk
about the book though
'cause you're like,
'Oh wait, fans might
not be caught up this.'
- Yes, yes.
- And book two ends on
a major cliffhanger,
so I can't even like
explain the beginning.
Like just the general
premise of this third book.
- Is that normal by the way?
Like last night, I mean,
even Vulture wrote
something about you, like,
you did this release and
like it just blew up.
It literally was like Taylor
Swift was releasing an album,
like all these people showed up.
Is that normal?
I guess you feel like
a tool answering that.
- (laughing)
- I was like, wait,
that's a weird question.
But I mean, that's amazing impact.
- You know what, you know, this
was actually my first event,
like in person event since Covid.
So this was kinda like my first time
like back in the flesh.
- Well, by the way, you're in demand.
Look at that.
Like, well that's, you're
doing, you're doing it right.
- It was amazing.
It was just amazing being out there
and like seeing the
readers face to face again
after so many years and...
- And you've created this
world, like whichever series,
you know, they're addicted to or into.
Like you've created this whole world
that y'all are all a part of.
That's really cool.
- Yeah, no, I mean it still
feels like a dream come true.
Like I wanted to be a writer
since I was 16 years old.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah, and so to get to do that.
- What made you wanna, like,
what turned you on to
reading in the first place?
- I mean, I was just like a weird kid.
I mean I grew up during a
time when like liking fantasy
sci-fi was like not cool.
Like you could get like
thrown in a trash can
at school For liking those things.
And my parents were big readers,
but they were more like
intellectual readers.
And so I was this like
weird changeling child
who just appeared and was like,
'I like fantasy and I like Star Wars.'
And thankfully my parents indulged that
and they, you know, let me kind of read
where my heart wanted to go.
And by the time I was 12 I knew
that I loved reading fantasy novels.
And then I just quickly realized I wanted
to not just read them,
I wanted to write them
and I wanted to write stories
about young women like
kicking,
I dunno if I can say ass ?
Can I say ass?
- Let's just say it.
Kicking ass , yeah
- Kicking ass.
And also like the romance.
Like I was, I didn't really
like the books I read in school
because there was never any magic,
but there was really like
not enough kissing for me.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God.
Your parents probably had a ball.
- My parents had no
idea what I was reading.
- My parents had no idea or my mom
had no idea what I was listening to.
I was like, oh yeah,
I'm totally listening,
just Michael Louis Smith, mom, that's it.
- (laughing)
- Like, which I love by the way.
- I think it's nice when
like your parents just like,
they don't hover too much and
they just like let you like
love the things that you're gonna love.
- I don't think she let me do that.
She, she didn't know I was listening
to TLC Red Light Special.
- Really?
- Yeah, she didn't know.
- See my parents were just like,
I don't know.
They were busy ......
- I think there's beauty in
that and then letting your,
like you become who
you're gonna be become.
- My five-year-old son, he's
already, the other night
before we went to the
midnight release party,
I got all glammed up and I came out
and did the big reveal to all my friends
that were at my house and they
were all, you know, so happy.
Then my son goes, you
look like an old rat.
(audience laughing)
- My, what is it with sons?
So my son will judge every outfit I wear.
I come down to go out with my girlfriends
and he literally was like,
'Oh, so you're gonna wear that.'
(audience laughing)
- (laughing)
- Like, I was styled today
by an actual stylist.
- I know.
- I was like, he saw me sitting
in the chair for two hours
having everything done.
- This took work
- And time
And like, yeah, I don't
know what it's about sons.
They're very honest.
- Oh my god, vicious.
- Meanwhile, my daughter's just like,
you look fine mom, you look great.
And she's like trying to like
dance on coals to make it better.
- I know, I know but that like....
- I mean I guess I like that
they're bold and honest,
but you know, I didn't ask
- Yeah, I mean, old rat
I was like, well you know what,
rats are very intelligent so
I take that as a compliment.
- Exactly.
Turn it around, filter it.
I like it.
A house of flame and shadow,
the third book in her Crescent
City series is out now
and everyone is going home with a copy.
You lucky people
(audience clapping and cheering)
Up next we got a must see
performance from the cast of
Kimberly Akimbo.
We'll be right back